just like Trump we're skipping the White
House correspondent Center in Washington
DC and instead are here in his rally in
Washington Township Michigan a fake name
yeah
everyone is here in the middle of some
sort of field to celebrate Trump who is
the first president in recent history to
greatly not face his critics is this
better that that phony Washington White
House
[Applause]
this is more fun than getting mocked by
the press you're always mocking so we're
talking to real Americans to get their
hot takes on the Correspondents Dinner
I think it's time for the elitist to
pump each other up and be bullies to
anyone who doesn't think like they do
yeah it's a bunch of like-minded people
getting together to hear what they want
to hear the White House Correspondents
Dinner a bunch of fake press or roasted
Trump yeah what would you say to roast
the big press your facts are so crooked
that you belong with Hillary yeah that's
it which is where jail we should lock up
the free breath exactly do you think
Trump is funny yes yes he's hilarious
he is subtle he's settled you gotta see
this guy I don't know what I said so
subtle but because these Trump errs
weren't invited to the White House
Correspondents Dinner we're giving them
the opportunity to roast the lamestream
media at the first annual counter
Correspondents Dinner
[Music]
knock knock who's there
Hillary Hillary Hillary is going to jail
Trump 2020 everybody's here because
Donald walks on water in first the
immigrants keep them away he's doing the
right thing it definitely starts as a
joke
yeah one yeah yeah CNN they just won't
report all the goodies doing because
they're afraid when people know what
he's doing that we'll all vote for him
but win the popular vote 100% CNN is so
fake they actually need to start taking
pictures of Donald Trump and join
remaking of America and making America
great again and when you go to a foreign
country you can only get CNN or
something like that yeah where they
speak English so either America has to
go multilingual or we need to do
something besides CNN you know it's sort
of long for a joke but I love it let's
end the fake news and keep the people
happy yeah give them what they want for
H justice and freedom yeah Thank You
president Trump I'll be by your side
every minute of the day love it like
this is what the Correspondents Dinner
should I don't think he will get my drum
set just cuz the security but you know
yes
Trump is the bigger man for skipping an
event that's just gonna be a bunch of
wheat jokes at the expense of others
anyway here are some nicknames for the
big news journalists Anderson Cooper
Anders and C Cooper Nancy Cooper a bigot
what do you think about MSNBC I masala
Steve MS LSD there's just record Rachel
Maddow little boy meadow little boy
Maddow
that's good you almost look like Rachel
you roasted me all right the jokes may
have needed some work but the message
was clear what'd she do with the free
press like Trump said lock him up
ultimately we love their enthusiasm but
these Trump errs weren't trained
performers so as self-proclaimed
comedians we decided to step up to the
plate and deliver some clever commentary
take the first amendment okay no
seriously take away the free press a
reporter from the New York Times and one
from CNN walk into a bar sorry I
misspoke walk into a place with bars a
prison cause either should put him in
jail just like Trump
we know that the mainstream media is a
joke fake dude they are very very
dishonest people yes the news it's a
fake and we don't need it Danny
trumpet drain the swamp until it's an
empty husk join us
[Music]